From Kim's uncertain future to the fate
of various "Breaking Bad" characters,
here's what we're still wondering about
after the final season of "Better Call Saul".
Of all places, why did the wealthy criminal lawyer
escape to the cold and unforgiving land of Omaha,
Nebraska? Was it just an obscure location to avoid
being captured? After all, it almost was as Gene
does go unnoticed for a matter of time before
former Albuquerque cab driver Jeff recognizes
him. However, this location is actually both
a reference to a throwaway line from "Breaking
Bad" and an important place from Kim Wexler's
past. Saul tells Walt as they hide out under the
vacuum repair shop in the "Breaking Bad" episode
"Granite State" a prediction of his future.
"If I'm lucky, a month from now, best-case
scenario, I'm managing a Cinnabon in Omaha."
This scene is revisited in the series finale of
"Better Call Saul" and also serves as a set-up
for the prequel series. The sad fulfillment
of this line is accompanied by a gorgeous
black and white composition that captures the
emptiness of the icing-slinging Gene Takovic.
However, that may not be the only reason Saul
hides out here. As we learn in Season 6, from
Kim's flashback earring thievery, she's actually
from Omaha, as seen on her mother's license plate.
Was Saul originally hoping Kim may have returned
here and chosen Nebraska in hopes of a reunion?
Before we flash-forward to full Saul, we
witness the devastating breakup of Jimmy
and Kim. Once again, the exact timeline is a
little unclear. It's hard to pinpoint just how
long it's been since Kim made that difficult
decision due to the artful way in which the
series portrays the passage of time. So the
question is — how long was Jimmy left alone
before he received a fat check from a
case he first discovered in Season 1?
It would be interesting to know how long Jimmy
was forced to sit with himself before Saul crept
up and fully took over his persona and life.
Who gave him the call updating him on the case
now that Hamlin, Hamlin & McGill is fully
dissolved? Was it a reluctant conversation
with a Davis & Main representative? Or
could it possibly have been Erin Brill,
his old co-worker who kept a close
eye on Jimmy during his time there?
Manuel Varga — Nacho's father — played a pivotal
role in his son's final episodes. The automobile
upholstery shop owner and upstanding citizen
was the epitome of good in a series full
of morally gray characters and others who
have intentionally broken bad. Thankfully,
Nacho was able to share a tear-jerking goodbye
with his father before he met his untimely demise.
However, the question remains — what was the fate
of Manuel? The last we saw of Nacho's father,
Mike paid him a visit to let him know that
his son died a good man. Thematically,
Mike gave Manuel a sense of closure
Mike will never have while providing
viewers with another redeeming moment for
the ex-officer and further revealing his
honorable true nature. While we may never see
Manuel again, thanks to Mike he will at least
have some sense of closure as he presumably
continues to work in his shop. Hopefully,
without Nacho around Manuel will be safe from the
cartel as he can no longer be used as leverage.
"If you are true to your word, there will be
no reason for anyone to harm your father."
There were very few joyful moments
in the grim series finale. However,
Kim Wexler remains one of the show's
most hopeful characters who still
seems worthy of true redemption. In
a strict exercise of self-discipline,
Kim settles for a simple life living in
Florida working at Palm Coast Sprinklers,
where she creates brochures and catalogs for the
company. After her explosive call with Saul, she
takes accountability for her actions by confessing
to her part in Howard's death and volunteering at
her local free legal clinic. Kim soon returns to
her true nature by burying herself in paperwork.
In an interview with Entertainment Weekly,
Rhea Seehorn breaks down this turn of events
and what it might mean for Kim's future, saying,
"I think she's thinking two things:
One, that it's possible that I can
allow myself to find some joy and
passion in my life again. And two,
that it's possible that I can atone for my actions
in an active way, instead of just a passive way."
She expands on Kim's more authentic altruism
and even teases a possible future reunion with
Jimmy — all of which is tied into the cathartic
decision to acknowledge her past mistakes.
The double-edged sword with Kim finding
happiness again is there is now someone
out there who wants to snatch it away. After Kim
remorsefully unveils her role in Howard's death,
she brings her completed statement to his
widow in an attempt to make amends. Cheryl
Hamlin is understandably livid at this
revelation and threatens to sue Kim in
civil court for everything she has in
the event that Kim avoids prosecution.
With the overall lack of evidence or witnesses
available to implicate Kim in Howard's death,
it seems unlikely that she'll be prosecuted,
especially after Jimmy clears her name in the
series finale. However, should Cheryl learn
that Kim has re-entered the law and is even
on speaking terms with her convicted ex-husband
Jimmy, the wronged widow may seek vengeance.
This could involve taking Kim to civil court
as promised and even exposing her past to her
new associates in Florida, potentially
shattering Kim's fragile fresh start.
After Jimmy weaponizes the
law in Saul's signature style,
he has a sudden change of heart after seeing
Kim. However, this ultimately lands him in a
far less luxurious prison than he originally
worked out for himself. His initial sweet
deal of seven years is increased to a crushing
sentence of 86 after his astonishing admission
of guilt, in which he details his actions
in shielding Heisenberg from prison during
his crime reign. He protects Kim and even
displays remorse for not doing more to save
his brother Chuck and admits the role he played
in the events that led to his brother's tragic
death. As star Bob Odenkirk stated during
an interview with Entertainment Weekly,
"It's the bravest, most honest thing he can do."
The series finale sees Jimmy return to using
his birth name while serving his sentence at the
very prison he wanted to avoid: ADX Montrose, as
indicated by the letters on his jumpsuit. However,
ADX Montrose may not be the final stop for
Jimmy, as Rhea Seehorn offers a ray of hope
with Entertainment Weekly that suggests he could
be seeing more of his ex-wife. Seehorn explained,
"I think she's going to go through a
very complicated process of trying to
figure out if she can help decrease
his sentence in a way that is still
just. And I don't think that's the last time
they'll see each other. Not by a long shot."
The last three episodes of "Better
Call Saul" intertwine with the original
series in some interesting ways. In
the Season 6's third to last episode,
aptly titled "Breaking Bad," Gene catches up
with his old secretary Francesca, played by Tina
Parker. She updates him on the fate of a few of
Walt's old accomplices. The first is Walt's widow,
Skyler White, who presumably got her deal
with the DEA, although she also mentions
that Jesse Pinkman's abandoned El Camino was
found somewhere near the border of Mexico. So,
where are Skyler and her son, Walter Jr., now?
When viewers last saw them in the "Breaking
Bad" series finale, they were living in
a small apartment and attempting to live
quiet lives. That could be the reason why they
didn't accompany Marie to face Jimmy in court.
Walter Jr. is in for some good news though,
as he still has the $9.7 million coming for
his 18th birthday from Walter's leftover
drug money in the form of an irrevocable
Trust from Elliot and Gretchen's
company, Grey Matter Technologies.
Marie's unexpected appearance in the
finale was an enormous delight for
both the fans and crew. "Better Call
Saul" co-creator Peter Gould praised
actress Betsy Brandt's return during
an interview with Variety. He said,
"I was so grateful that she was willing to come
to Albuquerque. She has a couple of scenes,
so she was there for quite a while. Working with
her reminded me of what a brilliant actress she
is, and every time she did her scenes, she
would bring something a little different."
Viewers can also be confident that
underneath all that beautiful black
and white footage used in the final episode
of "Better Call Saul," Marie was draped in
her signature purple while delivering
on of the best lines of the series:
"They tell me they found you in a garbage
dumpster. Well, that makes sense."
When "Breaking Bad" ended in 2013, most
fans thought we'd seen the last of Walt
and Jesse. However, even then there was some
comfort in knowing that the universe would
continue with the already announced prequel
spin-off about the loudmouth criminal lawyer,
Saul. However, now we are facing the
possible conclusion of the entire franchise.
Still, there is a shred of hope
remaining thanks to some recent
comments that Peter Gould made to The
Hollywood Reporter which suggest that
this may not be the end of the
"Breaking Bad" saga. Gould said,
"Look, if Vince or I or any of the folks
who worked on the show had an idea that we
were excited about, never say never. Vince
and I both feel like we want and need to do
something different and change things up.
If we ever did come back to this universe,
hopefully we bring a new set of ideas that would
enrich it and give us something different."
Deadline recently reported
that Vince Gilligan's next
show is going to be an Apple TV+
exclusive starring Rhea Seehorn,
but isn't expected to be related to the
stories of Better Call Saul and Breaking Bad.
While this is certainly an exciting
new direction for Gilligan,
fans are still hoping for a return to
Albuquerque in the not-too-distant future.
"Fantastic! Phew. That makes my life much easier."